in a previous video you saw how to
compute derivatives and implement
gradient descent with respect to just
one training example for Lich's
regression now we want to do it for M
training examples to get started let's
remind ourselves of the definition of
the cost function J cost function WP
which you care about is this average
right 1 over m sum from I equals 1
through m you know the loss when your
algorithm output a I on the example why
we're you know AI is D prediction on the
I've trained example which is Sigma of
Zi which is equal to Sigma of W
transpose X plus B ok so what we show in
the previous line is for any single
training example how to compute you know
the derivatives when you have just one
training example
great so dw1 d w2 and d be with now the
superscript I to denote the
corresponding values you get if you were
doing what we did on the previous slide
but just using the one training example
X I Y I those use me missing on I there
as well so now you notice the overall
cost function the sum was really the
average gives a 1 over m term of the
individual losses so it turns out that
the derivative respect to say w1 of the
overall cost function is also going to
be the average of derivatives respect to
w1 of the individual loss terms but
previously we have already shown how to
compute this term as say d w1 I right
which we you know on the previous slide
show how the computers on a single
training example so what you need to do
is really compute these um derivatives
as we showed on the previous training
example and average them and this will
give you the overall gradient that you
can use to implement gradient descent
so I know there was a lot of details but
let's take all of this up and wrap this
up into a concrete algorithms and what
you should implement together to see
regression with gradient descent working
so here's what you can do let's
initialize J equals 0 DW 1 equals 0 DW 2
equals 0 DB equals 0 and what we're
going to do is use a for loop over the
training set and compute the derivatives
with respect to each training example
and then add them up all right so here's
we do for I equals 1 through m so M is
the number of training examples we
compute Z I equals W transpose X I plus
B the prediction AI is equal to Sigma of
zi and then you know let's let's add up
j j plus equals y i log a i plus 1 minus
y i log 1 minus AI and then this put a
negative sign in front of the whole
thing and then as we saw earlier we have
d zi or it is equal to AI minus y i and
DW gets plus equals x1 i d zi d w2 plus
equals x i2 d zi o and i'm doing this
calculation assuming that you have just
feet two features so that n is equal to
2 otherwise you do this for DW 1 DW
tunity number 3 and so on and then g p+
equals d zi
and i guess that's the end of the for
loop and then finally having done this
for all M training examples you will
still need to divide by M because we're
computing averages so d w1 if I equals m
DW to 2 Phi cos M DB devising cost M in
all the computer bridges and so with all
of these calculations you've just
computed the derivative of the cost
function J with respect to e 3
parameters w1 w2 and be just a couple
details of what we're doing we're using
DW 1 + DW 2 and DP 2 as accumulators
so that after this computation you know
DW 1 is equal to D derivative of your
overall cost function with respect to W
1 and similarly for DW 2 and DB so
notice that DW 1 + DW to do not have a
superscript I because we're using them
in this code as accumulators to sum over
the entire training set whereas in
contrast DZ I here this was d Z with
respect to just once single training
example so that's why that had a
superscript I to refer to the one
training example either that's computed
on and so having finished all these
calculations to implement one step of
gradient descent you implement W 1 gets
updated as W 1 minus a learning rate
times D W 1 W 2 kids up patients W 2 -
learning rate times DW 2 and B gets
updated as B - learning rate times G B
where DW 1 DW + DB where you know as
computed and finally J here would also
be a correct value for your cost
function so everything on this slide
implements just one single step of
gradient descent and so you have to
repeat everything on this slide multiple
times in order to take multiple steps of
gradient descent in case these details
seem too complicated again don't worry
too much about it for now hopefully all
this would be clearer when you go and
implement as in G programming assignment
but it turns out there are two
weaknesses with the calculation as well
as we've implemented it here which is
that to implement logistic regression
this way you need to write to for loops
the first for loop is this for loop over
the M training examples and the second
for loop is a for loop over all the
features over here right so in this
example we just had two features so n
it's equal to 2 and x equals 2 but if
you have more features you end up
writing yo DW 1 DW 2 and here similar
computations for DW 3 and so on down to
DW n so it seems like you need to have a
for loop over the features over our n
features when you're implementing deep
learning algorithms you find that having
explicit
for loops in your code makes your
algorithm run less efficiency and so in
the deep learning error would move to
bigger and bigger data sets and so being
able to implement your algorithms
without using explicit for loops is
really important and will help you to
scale to much bigger data sets so it
turns out that there are set of
techniques called vectorization
techniques that allow you to get rid of
these explicit full loops in your code I
think in the pre deep learning era
that's before the rise of deep learning
vectorization was a nice to have you
could sometimes do it to speed Agricole
and sometimes not but in the deep
learning era vectorization that is
getting rid of for loops like this and
like this has become really important
because we're more and more training on
very large datasets and so you really
need your code to be very efficient so
in the next few videos we'll talk about
vectorization and how to implement all
this without using even a single full
loop so of this I hope you have a sense
of how to implement the gistic
regression or gradient descent for
logistic regression things will be
clearer when you implement the program
exercise but before actually doing the
program exercise let's first talk about
vectorization so that you can implement
this whole thing implement in single
iteration of gradient descent without
using any full news